mesdames et messieurs bonsoir à partir
de demain lundi les agents bien que soit
braves gens se montreront très sévère à
l'égard des automobilistes qui ne rompt
pas bouclé leur ceinture
par ailleurs un journal officiel publie
un décret imposant aux automobilistes de
ne plus circuler de la tombée de la nuit
en feux de position mais en code les
précisions par jean marc loos dès demain
un nouveau réflexe les codes sont
obligatoires dès la tombée de la nuit en
ville dans de nombreux pays
l'adoption de cette disposition a
considérablement amélioré la sécurité
il ne s'agit pas tant de voir que d'être
vu attention aussi à votre ceinture la
période de tolérance s'achève il vous en
coûtera 80 francs si vous êtes pris en
défaut une somme que sont prêts à payer
10 7% d'irréductibles en croire un
sondage publié aujourd'hui
en revanche 44 % de ceux qui accepteront
de la boucler le ferons dit le sondage
uniquement par peur du gendarme
l'obligation de rouler en code en
agglomération était depuis longtemps
attendue la publication ce matin au
journal officiel du décret d'application
a surpris deux contraintes nouvelles de
réflexes auquel les conducteurs vont
devoir s'habituer
demain lundi en fin de matinée paris
accueillera un visiteur de marque
monsieur bako fang qui est le numéro 1
du gouvernement chinois est le numéro un
du parti communiste chinois
avant de se rendre en allemagne en
grande-bretagne puisent en italie j'ai
un copain qui séjournera en france
pendant cinq jours savenay un événement
de portée exceptionnelle car elle
consacre la place de premier plan que la
chine populaire et occupe désormais dans
le concert des nations
rappelons que la france a été depuis la
naissance de la république populaire
chinoise
le premier pays occidental à envoyer un
ambassadeur apic les cision prises dès
1964 par le général de gaulle avant de
suivre l'analyse faite par georges
bortoli des aspects politiques du voyage
voici un portrait du visiteur par
bernard benyamin c'est d'abord sa
jeunesse qui nous a frappé dimanche
dernier
lorsqu'on compagnie d'autres
journalistes occidentaux croient pas aux
fins nous recevait au palais du peuple
à 59 ans en effet il est l'un des plus
jeunes membres du bureau politique
il est en excellente santé doté d'une
capacité de travail étonnante bref tout
ce que l'on voit d'attendre d'un homme
qui préside aux destinées d'un milliard
de chinois
il ne reste plus rien ou presque de ce
jeune paysan entrée par la petite porte
du parti et qui a su au long des années
gravir les échelons de la hiérarchie
trois copains est aujourd'hui un
dirigeant sûr de lui détendu et qui
répond sans nervosité aux questions les
plus délicates à xavi deux traits domine
la personnalité d'une soeur de marché
euromix il aime rire à l'origine noah ne
viennent pas en plaine il ratera donc
c'est avec le jeune roumaine pour un
voyage en europe sert à l'arrivée un an
ensuite et surtout il a su s'entourer
d'un infarctus qui peut sur sa vie
privée en asie afin qu'il est marié mais
personne ne connaît sa femme c'est
normal disent aujourd'hui avec un
certain humour les chinois son
prédécesseur a eu tellement de problèmes
avec la sienne même chan chin qui fait
partie de la bande des classes que le
président roy ne veut prendre aucun
risque
voilà donc très rapidement l'homme qui
arrive demain paris symbole d'une
nouvelle politique menée avec un trident
moyens sous ne doivent plus rien annoncé
tout cela dit qu'est ce que les chinois
attendent de la france et qu'est ce que
la france attend des chinois vont
évidemment la question qu'on se pose
avant ce voyage de monsieur wac ont fait
sur le plan économique c'est clair les
chinois ont besoin de l'occident de la
technique occidental pour réaliser leurs
fameuses quatre modernisations dont nous
avons beaucoup entendu parler ces
jours-ci quand nous préparions à pékin
les émissions vous avez pu voir sur
antenne 2 reconnaissant les thm ans que
nous français nous ne sommes pas les
mieux placés parmi les occidentaux sur
ce plan là puisque en 1976 la france
était le quatrième fournisseur de la
chine et qu'elle n'est plus aujourd'hui
que au huitième rang cela dit tout de
même sur le plan en valeur absolue en
millions de francs si vous voulez les
échanges s'accroissent quand même et
tout indique qu'il s'accroîtront encore
à brécé piste alors sur le plan
politique il ya bien entendu le coup de
chapeau de pékin à paris parly choisie
comme première étape
cette visite européenne souvenir de ce
31 janvier 1964 où de gaulle premier de
tous les chefs d'état occidentaux
renvoyer un ambassadeur à pékin
les constatations du fait que avec sa
puissance nucléaire indépendante avec sa
liberté d'aller où vis-à-vis des
etats-unis la france joue un rôle
politique qui intéresse pékin voilà
alors la chine la chine puissance
atomique depuis 15 ans la chine grande
très grande puissance aujourd'hui la
chine aujourd'hui aborde les problèmes
internationaux avec plus de calme et
moins de crispation
ça n'est pas la grande des crispations
encore n'y a qu'à voir la terrible lutte
d'influencé qui se déroule actuellement
en asie du sud est
au cambodge par exemple mais enfin tout
de même et nous allons le vérifier ces
jours-ci pendant cette visite
le mot de détente ne fait plus levé les
épaules aux chinois
monsieur bakofeng sera accueilli par le
président de la république lequel
quittera l'aéroport avec son hôte en
hélicoptère pour atterrir à l'école
militaire
le cortège gagnera de là l'hôtel marigny
résidence du numéro un chinois à paris
en longeant l'hôtel des invalides puis
en prenant l'esplanade et pour traverser
la seine et à partir du pont alexandre
iii
la garde républicaine à cheval et sa
fanfare précéderont protège en iran la
nouvelle constitution va offrir des bois
représentant du allied l'arménie
confirme ainsi la supériorité de l'élu
de dieu sur l'élu du peuple que sera le
président de la république entre autres
l'ayatollah sera commandant suprême des
forces armées
et c'est lui qui le cas des chiens
décidera si le président de la
république doit ou non être destitué il
ya quinze ans jour pour jour où
surcouche soit été limogé et monsieur
brejnev le remplaçait le chancelier
allemand helmut schmidt vient de
commenter le tout récent discours est un
peu vers l'est pour monsieur schmitt de
l'hiver soviétique en soulignant la
volonté de son pays de négocier entend
ne pas risquer qu'on remette en question
l'oeuvre de sa vie la politique russe de
détente à l'égard de l'occident mais
ajoute le chancelier le discours
contient d'évident tentative
d'intimidation bref pour monsieur
schmitt
il ne faut ni se bercer d'espoir a
justifié ni se faire des soucis
injustice
coup de filet spectaculaire de la police
espagnole à barcelone madrid et valence
en quelques jours elle a arrêté 21
membres du groupe terroriste le drapeau
avec son chef c'est maria sanchez et
d'importants stocks d'armes ont été
saisies ce tri nations le drapeau g rap
et hausser le groupe de résistance
antifasciste du premier octobre
responsable avec l'été à le mouvement
autonomiste basque de la plupart des
attentats commis ces dernières années
carlos garcia valdès directeur de
l'administration pénitentiaire est sans
doute l'homme qui a le plus fait pour
humaniser les prisons profondément
démocrate ce jeune fonctionnaire connu
pour sa modération est la seule
personnalité à avoir échappé à un
attentat du drapeau pour quoi vous
attendez vous mon prédécesseur avait été
assassiné un enfant juste avant
l'attentât dont j'ai je pense que le
drapeau voulait faire de cette charge de
directeur de l'administration
pénitentiaire jean charest le fait que
j'ai réformé les prisons et que je sois
connu comme un progrès si on ne change
rien de la vraie revient de faire c'est
un argument de plus pour être associé
le but des terroristes c'est de mettre à
bas à l'ordre public par tous les moyens
déstabilisé la jeune démocratie
espagnole elle semble bien avoir été le
but des grapo qui ont revendiqués à ce
jour pas de cinquante assassinats et une
centaine d' attentats dont celui du café
california qui affirmait dernier vit
morts et 42 blessés à madrid
pourtant les cibles favorites du drapeau
entêté des militaires des policiers ou
des personnalités judiciaire d'ailleurs
dans les fichiers saisis lors de
l'arrestation de leur chef 3 et maria
sanchez
on a prouvé une liste de 3000 noms de
personnalités diverses
avec pour chacun les détails de sa vie
de ses habitudes et de ses itinéraires
pourtant une inconnue demeure ces
grappes hôtes se proclame anti fasciste
qui se réclame de l'orthodoxie
stalinienne et considère le parti
communiste espagnol comme un parti
traître tel maître serbe est il vraiment
car après tout leurs actions a servi
depuis toujours des intérêts divergents
c'est la veille à emerson bourges dont
je n'ai pas les joies de qualifier les
étiquettes qui pensent que c'est
rentable d attaquer et la démocratie et
les systèmes démocratiques en disant
qu'il n'est pas assez à révolutionnaire
sinon il ya la joie des gens qui
détestent système démocratique parce
qu'il croit qu'il est contraire à leurs
intérêts ils sont en vie démocratique
parce qu'ils veulent en état autoritaire
et bien cela j'ai sont aussi contents
des tl est à l'origine d'une certaine
façon des mondes là une stabilité plus
d'institutions démocratiques
les tango sous extrême droite le but
immédiat des grapo est clair créer le
désordre pour amener les militaires qui
sont des vrais arbitres de la situation
politique en espagne les amenés à
intervenir dans la vie politique du pays
et créer ainsi une situation explosive
heureusement depuis la mort de franco
les militaires ont joué le jeu de la
démocratie en espagne et sont restés
dans leurs casernes france en début de
soirée au club de la presse européenne
un monsieur michel rocard a
principalement parlé des questions
économiques mais il a aussi réaffirmé
qu'il ne serait pas candidat aux
présidentielles de 80 si monsieur
françois mitterrand se présenter six
premiers secrétaires du parti socialiste
se représentait pas il appartiendrait
aux socialistes ajouter votre carte de
décider qui serait le candidat et ce
sont dans les procédures qui sont celles
du pacte
je pense que tout candidat socialiste
qui diviserait son propre parti serait
un mauvais candidat de la procédure je
peux ma porte je suis socialiste à moi
elle importe cette procédure là si ce
n'est qu'une procédure ses plus nobles
que ça la capacité de rassembler obtenu
volonté commune de cent mille personnes
il donne assez de temps à leur travail à
leurs efforts publics pour porter en
commun une volonté qu'ils proposent au
pays de prendre en charge et moi je la
respecte et ce n'est pas de la procédure
excusez moi de plus je pense que la
paire est si grave qu'elle doit être
traitée sérieusement mais il se trouve
il faut ajouter à cela une autre
remarque c'est qu'il est mauvais pour la
france d'être en campagne électorale
permanente et souhaitez vous
personnellement que françois mitterrand
sur le candidat socialiste ne venons pas
grand chose à voir dans cette affaire
le candidat n'est pas auto désigné chez
nous il est partenaire barre de 100
milliards allemande entre le personnel
n'est pas d'avis personnel sur la
question nos corps le parti radical
valoisien réunis en congrès du vendredi
à paris à lui aujourd'hui son nouveau
président seul il succède à monsieur
l'injection schubert un homme de 36 ans
didier bariani élection sans surprise il
était le seul candidat
ces gens lui le scène qui est suivi pour
nous les travaux des rhétiques
congrès sans surprise donc si ce n'est à
la danse comme on dise les radicaux le
tandem dargani photo a eu droit à
l'ovation des militants sans qu'une
opposition des stades et rien ou
d'ailleurs et plus affirmer nettement au
cours des débats
on peut noter quand même que le premier
vice président jean pierre rousseau qui
est secrétaire d'état à la petite et
moyenne industrie et qui était il n'y a
pas si longtemps le patron des
francs-maçons monsieur poteau a réalisé
un meilleur score que le président
lui-même
monsieur mariani ce qui aura sans aucun
doute des répercussions dans les mois
qui viennent au niveau de la direction
du parti
une direction qui se veut malgré tout
ouverte collégiale à la nuit
9e conclusion qu'on peut tirer de ce
congrès des radicaux qui se veulent une
grande famille
malgré leurs maigres résultats aux
élections récentes les radicaux sent
bien qu'il est nécessaire de rameuter
tous leurs fils prodigue un geste
précurseur dès ce matin la formation de
robert fabre a réintégré le parti
valoisien
enfin les radicaux veulent prendre dès
maintenant leurs distances vis-à-vis de
l'udf dont ils sont pourtant l'une des
composantes didier bariani a indiqué à
l'issue des travaux du congrès ce que
les radicaux comptait reprendre leur
liberté d'expression à l'égard de leurs
partenaires et même du gouvernement
reste à savoir jusqu'où ils pourront
aller dans cette voie à la fête de la
fédération socialiste du département du
doubs jean françois mitterrand premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste s'est
déclaré désolé de la décision des amis
de robert fabre de rejoindre le parti
radical décision dont vous parlez de
samedi un instant le parti radical de
droite a ajouté monsieur mitterrand et
celui de l'udf les radicaux de gauche
font partie de l'union de la gauche
passer de l'un à l'autre
c'est changer de camp une histoire
triste à liverdun traitement si une
centaine d'adolescents fumée du hse
drogué au point qu'une trentaine d'entre
eux paraissait avoir pris un goût
profond à la drogue
les principaux pourvoyeurs étaient des
jeunes de 14 à 17 ans élève au même
collège et qui pour acheter de la drogue
menaçait les faisait chanter d'autres
jeunes camarades et certaines très
jeunes filles cas par an 15 ans pour
gagner de poids se fournir en viande
utilisée
comment dirais-je leur charme
rennes la faire et découverte la suite
de l'insistance d'une conseillère
municipale courageuse madame d'ennemis
qui est aussi assistante sociale et
selon la gendarmerie on se trouve devant
une entreprise de grande envergure et
qui s'étendrait à d'autres
agglomérations dans la région de nancy
les milieux l'asthmatique sont prêts à
tout pour ne plus souffrir de leur gêne
respiratoire quand la thérapeutique
officielle a échoué les allergiques à la
poussière de maison aux plumes aux poils
d'animaux et ses parts à la quête de
nouveaux moyens de remettre de bonnes
femmes plus ou moins de prouver et dont
ils attendent un et miracles
parmi ces remèdes un étrange régime à
base de l'autre caille prescrits sur
ordonnance a d'abord donné en charente
des résultats inattendus mais voici
qu'il intéresse aujourd'hui à recherche
médicale une enquête sur place de martin
avait régné sur le plat au raisin ou sur
cannes ac s'est jusqu'à présent en
gastronomie que les cas y ont fait leurs
preuves mais cela pourrait changer en
charente certains arcs roi des artistes
et rappelé éthiques
il sert vraiment à 15 ans la femme d'un
éleveur de gibier dramatiquement
allergique aux plumes perdu son accent
faisant sa cuisine aux oeufs de caille
aujourd'hui elle retravaille au musée
des plumes quelques amis allergiques
et c'est hier à leur tour avec succès la
faire par 21 médecins du coin qui décida
de s'occuper de cette troublante affaire
et d'en prescrire à ses clients un
éleveur de cairo dit dans le journal de
tijd bon rôle
cela coïncidait avec une malade qui
revenait avec un échec total de la
désensibilisation
j'ai essayé 1.792 caille vous le
considérez comme un aliment comme un
médicament disons comme un régime
diététique qui avaient les vertus de
médicaments et que n'importe qui peuvent
utiliser en allant au marché acheter des
trains après manger crus cuits n'apporte
tout en france je ne mens pas je suis
contre tout automédication à cause des
dangers que le traitement surtout je
n'avais
je représente c'est un traitement qui
doit être réservé aux médecins ces cas
l'allergie à l'oeuf peut être redoutable
la foi et attirer le choix toutefois il
nous est arrivé de récupérer certains
adultes
après de nombreux traitements mais
vraiment l'adulte n'est pas le terrain
de choix de cette série
ça commence et il avait deux ans et demi
j'ai quatre premières années d'école où
il est toujours malade du tout c'est
pourtant mon premier souci des bons
chiffres et j'ai essayé différents
traitements c'était toujours même point
s'arrêter à recommencer et on s'est
aperçu qu'il est allergique à
différentes sources ou poils de chien
poil de lapin la poussière et la poule
on avait tous à la maison
alors j'ai fait l'idiote les autres call
et la première fois bondage avons enlevé
loyers prime cela ça n'a pas marché
la deuxième fois j'ai reçu une cure en
mettant l'oreillette plus il a il
affirme que de 40 2
la dernière il ya eu ça remonte à trois
ans et depuis terminé plus bronchite
plus d'action tourné selon le modèle
en quatre ans nous parlons de
stabilisation dans l'absence de
symptômes ne parlons jamais de guérison
agriculteurs et vous avez des échecs
vrai c'est à dire des personnes qui
n'ont aucune amélioration
bien sûr est-ce que les allergologues
croire votre méthode certes oui certains
sont intéressés les autres je ne sais
pas
leur expérience personnelle permettra de
raison c'est dur pour un médecin
généraliste et sa très nette et
découvertes aux je me suis battue depuis
11 ans pour que des gens plus compétents
que moi près de 720 et que la grande
recherches soient lancées
ils mentent une expérimentation animale
je réclame à cor et à cri depuis des
années et qui enfin paraît
définitivement tranché
de fait un laboratoire de recherche
officiel prend le relais les expériences
en entreprise sur des rats
expérimentalement rendu allergiques et
que l'on vague avait neuf de kayes cru
le but est simple savoir si les
améliorations constatées sur les malades
sont dus au fait qu'il y croit beaucoup
d'action serait alors avant tout
psychologique ou six dans le blanc ou le
jaune de 6e et de ses 1 seulement existe
réellement une substance active qui
permet de venir à bout de toute sorte
d'allergie
pour le moment tous les doutes sont
permis aux proches ces temps derniers en
cesse de parler d'eux lors de ces plans
bête ces ragots laddh de ses 26 mai à
l'autre bout de la chaîne si je puis
dire
il faut aller découvrir le métal là où
ils se trouvent et bien depuis le début
du printemps une véritable ruée vers
l'or se détacher au pérou et
l'augmentation considérable du prix du
métal y est évidemment pour beaucoup les
prospecteurs françois principalement
leur des portes au coeur de la forêt
d'amazonie comme au siècle dernier par
la ruée vers l'or aux états unis il
suffit pour obtenir une concession de
délimiter un espace et de le faire
reconnaître par les services qualifiés
du gouvernement terry cap un reportage
d'abba de libye le nouvel eldorado se
trouve à huit heures de camion de cusco
sur les bords de la rivière madre de
dios là dans des terrains alluvionnaires
à 1 mètre 80 profondeur les indiens
trouve de l'or malgré les méthodes on ne
peut plus artisanal la production pour
cette concession qui utilisent 15
personnes atteint 80 grammes par jour
c'est du moins ce que l'on déclare
officiellement car il semble bien que
l'or soit vendu plan destine mans sans
passer par le monopole de l'état
péruvien qui achètent le kilo vingt-huit
mille francs mais il ne faut pas croire
que les indiens vont devenir moins
pauvres pour cela les concessions sont
prises par des personnes de lima cuzco
où d'autres villes ou par quelques
aventuriers l'hectare et concédé 12
centimes par an seuls ceux qui peuvent
investir en matériel pourront arriver
jusqu'aux paillettes les autres presque
toujours les indiens sont payés au mois
200 ou 300 francs selon le cas pour
sortir la terre
e
en
pour séparer l'or de sa gangue de sable
et de terre des ouvriers malaxe le
résidu avec du mercure
mais payet contenu dans le sable sont
dissoutes dans le métal liquide
pour garder lors il suffira de récupérer
le mercure après lavage
le moyen le moins coûteux c'est encore
la battait les produits les plus légers
partiront dans la rivière il ne restera
au fond du récipient que les plus lourds
les billes de mercure contenant
l'horizon
pour retrouver le métal précieux il
suffit de chauffer un vieux bidon fait
la faire sans aucun souci pour les
émanations toxiques
l'important c'est l'or qui sera vendue à
lasbordes
ces banques elles s'ouvrent dans chaque
village champignon qui pousse auprès des
gisements comme dans le far west à
l'époque de la ruée vers l'or la fièvre
a commencé ici il ya tout juste un an
beaucoup sont contaminés et arrivent
chaque jour pour certains des lointains
héritiers de blizzard qui n'ont pas
beaucoup de scrupules
l'ex empire inca c'est encore le pérou
le rc lens qui vient de terminer sur un
film c'est ce qui a pris neuf mois de
tournage de trois mois de montage
c'est un film de grand envergure disent
ce qu'ils ont vu en projection privée
il sortira sur les écrans français le 31
octobre
dans la campagne normande pendant huit
mois en inde polanski a dirigé la jeune
comédienne nastassja kinski dans le rôle
de tess tess d'après le roman de thomas
hardy raconte l'histoire d'une paysanne
que la fatalité conduira au meurtre tête
c'est aussi la vie rurale au rythme des
saisons
dans l'angleterre du siècle dernier dans
question de temps roman polanski dira
pourquoi il a fait ce film et il en
commentera des extraits mais cette
émission c'est aussi le portrait d'un
homme dont l'oeuvre est l'existence sont
ancrées dans notre époque et on donne un
témoignage d'exemplaires atterrissage à
perpignan le 22 juillet dernier le temps
d'un week end interrompant le montage de
tests en ans polanski honore
l'invitation du festival
cinématographique de prades qui lui rend
hommage 17 ans après son premier long
métrage le couteau dans l'eau couronné
ici même en 62 au nom de polanski né à
paris en 1933
bientôt il regagne la pologne avec ses
parents à 6 ans il regarde sans trop
comprendre s'élevait le mur du ghetto de
cracovie
la guerre éclate ses parents sont
déportés à auschwitz d'où sa mère ne
revient pas à 9 ans une patrouille
allemande lui tire dessus à 11 ans un
bombardement l'ensevelît sous les
décombres d'une maison
élevé par plusieurs familles il ne
retrouve son père rescapé des camps de
concentration qu'à 12 ans un an plus
tard il devient comédien son père se
remarie polanski n'aime pas ça il songe
à mémoire de sa mère
à 16 ans un voyou lui fracasse le crâne
et le laisse à demi mot il s'en sort et
rêve de cinéma
sa passion pour la réalisation le
conduit à entrer à l'école de l'os
l'une des plus réputées du monde ma
jeunesse m
l'évolution des cds des nazis artistique
se passait dans le surréalisme dans la
couse découvert des surréalistes en
pologne après la période stalinienne où
tout était hermétique on ne savait pas
que des choses comme ça existe et on
découvrait une littérature une teinture
et qui était est tout à fait opposés à
7,7 cette arête pouvant table qu'on
avait réalisé socialiste trois réussites
populaires ont marqué la carrière de
polanski le bal des vampires
une comédie qui jouent à faire peur et
démystifie la légende des nosferatu et
autres dracula rose mary baby
l'angoissent d'une femme qui croit être
enceinte d oeuvre de satan se surnaturel
envahi le quotidien les démons sont dans
les placards
chinatown une histoire de détective qui
n'a rien à voir avec les modèles du
genre la dérision et la fatalité plane
pluies s'abattent sur le destin d'un
homme pour le public polanski n'est pas
seulement un cinéaste connu en 1969
l'assassinât de sa femme sharon tate a
fait de lui le triste héros de la presse
à scandale plus récemment une affaire de
détournement de mineure qui n'est pas
encore placé le conduisait en prison
surtout cela polanski se piquera en
direct demain dans question de temps
course à longchamp entre surprise en
super yam sa course est importante de
l'année réservé aux tout jeunes chose
deux ans défaite de la grandissime
favorite princesse sida elle a été
battue par le terrain lourd surtout la
victoire est revenue à dragon de
l'écurie fut stade quant aux tirs ses
brigades vertes
il a été remporté par un concurrent du
bas de l'échelle des poids
sagement la route pavée qui a trouvé la
récompense de sa persévérance et les
brandt le terrain c'est très long chant
nous retrouvons les 1906 rendu car c'est
à la sortie du dernier tournant il reste
encore environ 700 mètres à parcourir
pour le moment ensemble le numéro 18 ces
règles ajoute le coût des prêts de vie
gloire dé avant leur art ronde grand
sérieux bien assez à la corde
chérubin et au milieu avec et tous
milieux avec la route avait au début de
la ligne droite les chevaux sont dans le
même ordre et à mi-ligne droite pour en
sérieux vous commencez son effort mais
vivent à être gênés à plusieurs titres
11e journée
à rennes-ii manque encore de sang froid
il évite qu'ils ne trouvent pas
l'ouverture gardien de la cavale blanche
sur convenu devant lui l' vous savez l
offre de dialoque fumant vers une fois
sur rubin est à la lutte avec la fronde
pour public numéro 10 c'est que nous
formons fiable et gros sérieux un de
ressources ou couper dans cet us open
ont couru en périphérie 20h foot
il faudra d'ailleurs l'aide de la faute
offensive se départager arrivé quelques
uns des sectes
c'est une lutte très serrée alors qu'à
un set qui vapeur dans leurs 2 108 81 98
105 ans et dans le désordre 500 945 150
la météo demain le temps sera orageux
dans la matinée des alpes à la corse
puissent deviendra instable avec exercer
averses
partout ailleurs il fera généralement
fret et brumeux le matin ensuite les
périodes ensoleillées prédominant
toutefois de nouveaux foyers de rageux
ce développement sur les pyrénées le
massif central et le pourtour
méditerranéen
car compte tenu des températures
moyennes demain ne mettez pas en service
votre chauffage demande de la jeunesse
déterminée rjc exception concerne le
jura le morvan l'auvergne et les
cévennes où le chauffage peut être
maintenu ou mise en service mais au
dessus de 350 mètres d'altitude sachez
qu'un semaine dernière vous étiez 4
millions de familles à choper cette
semaine il n'y en a plus que deux
millions ça fait un joli programme
notre édition est terminée c'est
pierre-alain qui vous présentera deux
derniers journal vers 23h20 demain
n'oubliez pas antenne 2010 présenté par
patrick pocock et le soir vous
retrouverez nous retrouverons patrick
poivre d'arvor
pourquoi